Let's go next to Alex from South Carolina.
You're on the air.
I mean, yes, it is, yeah, so I'm from South
Carolina, obviously, and I was to a lot of
political radio and as you can imagine, it's
mostly right leaning.
Yeah.
From what I've heard from Colin since the
election, I don't know if you know who Tom
Rice is, but he's a senator that represents
my district or congressman.
Excuse me.
OK, Collins from radio shows, they're basically
threatening to primary him because he voted
for impeachment.
So what I'm concerned of is in the next two
to four years, are we just going to see a
bunch of, like, radical Trump like characters
come from all these reliably safe Republican
districts?
And I'm afraid that the Republican Party is
going to get a lot more radical.
I don't think it's clear that that's going
to be the case.
I think it's possible.
But that one direction is the one you describe,
which is green.
Bobert and Cawthorn get reelected in twenty,
twenty two, along with a whole bunch of new
sort of Trump kuhnen cultist types.
That's one direction.
The other direction is if Donald Trump just
keeps his mouth shut.
I mean, we haven't heard from him essentially
for the ten days since he left office.
If he just keeps his mouth shut and more traditional
Republicans regain influence in the Republican
Party, then you may see the Trumpy in members
of Congress lose reelection in 2022 and no
one else get into power.
So I think your fear, you're right that it
could happen.
I don't think I'm ready to say that that's
the direction things are going.
We have to wait and see.
Really hope you're right, because I'm terrified
of where that party is headed.
Well, I'm not sure.
I'm not saying it won't be that way, but I'm
just saying I don't I don't have enough information
yet to say one way or the other.
Unfortunately, it's just going to be a wait
and see.
I just want to say thank you for taking my
call.
And I've been really excited to see your growth
on Twitter over the last year.
Thanks so much.
I appreciate it.
All right, take care.
Very good.
Yes.
Powerful, powerful growth is happening on
on Twitch for sure.
Let's go to Magnis from Scotland, Magnis from
Scotland.
You're on the air.
Magnus from Scotland, please unmount yourself
so that we can talk, you're on the air.
And last opportunity for Magnis from Scotland,
you were on the air.